plans for a firefly return continue to
gather Pace but there's been a Twist in
the tail could it be made by actually
somebody other than Disney
yes welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
[Music]
I think it's generally accepted that the
greatest sci-fi ever made is Firefly
Joss whedon's 14 episode a masterpiece
is still one of the most watched things
in my house and since appearing on
Disney plus it's done phenomenally well
this has led Disney Executives to
explore how they could possibly bring
this franchise back I reported to you
not long ago that actually they now
believe that the only way to bring it
back is if Nathan Fillion returns to his
role as Captain Reynolds and that he
would actually be willing the rookie has
currently been renewed for another
season but talking to person I actually
speak to he told them he wants to step
back a little bit from that role and
kind of already has been he loves being
in a series where there are many other
characters and that he doesn't
necessarily have to appear in every damn
scene like it used to have to do in the
castle
so all of a sudden he's got a little bit
more free time and he could potentially
take on a small project like maybe a
mini series or something else which I'm
going to talk about in a minute of the
Firefly
now currently that would be very easy
the Firefly is on ABC and ABC is owned
by Disney because they own everything
so in theory a firefly series that would
potentially appear on Disney plus could
easily be managed they could film next
door to each other they could maybe do a
mini-series or something else and this
is something that Nathan Fillion would
be very open to
but there is another possibility
Firefly movie now the serenity movie in
2005 didn't do great it's one of my
favorite films but it cost about 50
million dollars to make and it only took
50 million dollars at the box office so
even though it didn't lose money it was
not the runaway success people kind of
hoped it would be and there were rumors
about a sequel almost immediately but
they just never happened Nathan Philly
went on to do Castle he then went on
straight into the rookie so he has been
a very busy boy ever since anyway but
maybe that's the best option for Disney
make a movie look at what they've done
with Michelle yo and Star Trek over at
Paramount she didn't have time to do the
series they'd always hoped for so they
negotiated like crazy and agree to do a
short movie instead three maybe four
months of her life instead of six to
eight months every year for the next
seven years
could Nathan Fillion do that
well no because Disney don't own the
movie rights to Firefly Universal day
so when Fox canceled Firefly all those
years ago idiots I still I I can't
believe I mean sometimes you have to
question people's intelligence you know
sometimes you see people do something so
stupid that you just think I I despair
for Humanity and canceling Firefly is
one of those situations but they did
they canceled it defying interesting oh
God oh God we're all gonna die now Joss
Whedon fought for Firefly like crazy and
he tried to get it onto a different
network and nobody was biting but
Universal did say well
we could do a movie and Joss Whedon
jumped at the opportunity Universal
bought the movie rights and we got the
serenity film movie rights they still
own
now according to somebody that I've
spoken to this is a very real
possibility and has actually been
seriously considered and there might
have even been very very early
conversations with Nathan Fillion the
problem is that Disney have also had
early conversations with Nathan Fillion
so he can't do both according to a
source that I have that's reasonably
close to this he believes there may be
an alternative
partnership deals today are normal in
Hollywood big studios like to hedge
their bets they like to share the cost
of things so is it possible that we
could get a cooperation between
Universal and Disney to create a firefly
movie Serenity 2. well according to my
guy it's not just a possibility it has
already been discussed and the reason
why is very easy
as I said earlier the numbers on Disney
plus Firefly have done brilliantly
people watch it over and over again in a
recent poll Firefly was voted the number
one Sci-Fi show of all time and there
was oh well over a million people voted
in that poll so Disney just consider
this to be a massive opportunity
and Universal
well they've recently decided not to
pursue the Battle Star Galactica movie
and TV series so for them they're
thinking this could be a very
interesting project for potentially
peacock or even a straight to streaming
movie now where that movie would appear
is Up For Debate I suspect it would
appear on peacock in the United States
and Disney plus internationally but that
would be for them to decide
How likely do I think this is as a
possibility
well my source says that the
conversations have happened but this is
an incredibly difficult conversation to
have Nathan Fillion would jump at the
opportunity and so would pretty much the
entire cast
the only real shame for me is we won't
see Alan tudik unless he comes back as a
ghost or a memory or something else
because obviously he's dead
I'm a leaf on the Wind
and it would also be a terrible shame
not to see the great Ron Glass Play
Shepherd book one more time but sadly he
passed away this should do preacher
don't the Bible have some pretty
specific things to say about the killing
quite specific it is however somewhat
fuzzier on the subject of kneecaps we
could see the serenity fly once again we
could see River
with all her Madness and we could see
Kaylee in the engine room covered in
Greece which would be awesome
I would love to see this series return
even if it was just a limited short
series you know just to tap into that
and Nostalgia that we all love I mean
let's be honest Picard season 3 has
shown everybody how a good nostalgic TV
show can be done and how popular it
could be
if they did a limited series or a movie
or a couple of movies I'm going to be
first in that line to watch and I know a
lot of you will be as well so guys get
the comments tell me what you think
about this intriguing possibility
perhaps Firefly doesn't need to be made
by Disney after all perhaps Universal
could step in and save one of the
greatest franchises ever thought up
because there is also another slight
issue with Disney they don't
particularly want to work with Joss
Whedon but Universal have no such qualms
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where you get to
see most of our videos first and without
the adverts for a small contribution
each month that helps the channel
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]